what up what up Sparta Marcus clay and
you can catch me on the bootleg KF
podcast soon as possible yes sir
bootleg cat podcast special guest in
here man representing H-Town Marcus clay
what's the deal welcome sir how you
doing uh congratulations on dreamville
Fest yep appreciate it you're gonna be
performing the same day as Usher yep
Usher Usher baby how does that happen
it's like J Cole like because I'm sure
like Colin Ibrahim shout out to Eve they
probably have a lot of like they they
curate their show right so that you must
be on their radar pretty tough I hope I
am I don't know man shout out to my boy
Rob though shout out my boy Rob Gibbs
man I hope I'm on and B mems of course
my manager should I be but I I hope I
hope I'm on it radar
um you uh I first saw you you opened up
for Joyner Lucas and Simba on tour and I
was like oh this kid's dope and I
followed you I saw you're on Def Jam but
um how long have you been making music
man and uh obviously you're a young you
look young how old are you 23. okay yeah
you're young okay how long you've been
doing this [__] for real for real though
I've been doing it honestly for 12 years
professionally like recording actually
like putting uh effort into it but I've
been in love amusing my whole life right
you know what I'm saying what made you
like fall in love my mom my mom was an
artist your mom's here yeah she was
artist yeah she was a rapper singer so
okay we're gonna have Mom coming
freestyle too it's Age come on I'm
pretty sure she would she would we gotta
pull up that shine beat for Mom for sure
nah she can kill it but now I just you
know my mom was in the studio you know
she when she was my age you know I'm
saying 23 24 so as a young and I was
just watching her and I just knew what I
wanted to do from there at what level
was like did your mom end up like did
she sign a deal or was she she was
shopped around she she was looking at it
the Atlantic was looking at her like in
2008 2009 and you know she was doing her
thing yeah so that was like right after
the Screwed Up era right that was like
the Swisher house arrow
down a little bit yeah yeah yeah right
yep yeah oh 809 yep and then I started
taking it serious to 2010. so when you
were a little kid were you like
listening to [__] Mike Jones and Slim
Thug and all that [__] I was listening I
was listening to them but I was more
like my influence because you you rap
like you know yeah you're signed a dream
bill right yeah well I mean that's what
they say I'm not gonna say right like
but that you know that that's what I
feel like I try to put out there and
convey in my music but um I was on like
J big beans and US pot Beanie Sigel huh
yeah for sure beans are one of the most
underrated dudes ever ever of all time
what Beanie Sigel album did you
gravitate towards I like the becoming I
like the true I like all of them the
truth and they're becoming probably my
top two the truth is the one the first
one yeah for sure if you live by the
sword you die by the sword I might die
in the vocal booth spitting out raw yo
shout out to Beanie Siegel yeah sure
beans damn yeah so you got some pretty
serious like uh East Coast influence
yeah yep obviously legends from Texas
though shout out to UGK shout out to
absolutely I grew up on them too face
Scarface zero J Dog uh Scarface what's
your favorite Scarface album
it's too many to come I'll say my top
three
Untouchable the fix and the diary the
diary yeah I mean the fix is like I feel
like the fix was like his like second
like a lot he got a new fans off like a
lot of new fans off the fix right
absolutely because the fix was like kind
of like his last real commercial like
album and it was like when he was
running Def Jam yeah he was the man yeah
he's still a man that dude he's the
truth yeah Scarface is one of the goats
for sure
um so kind of walk me through like how
you ended up getting on Def Jam's radar
like at what point in time did you
really catch a buzz out of Houston man
this [__] was organic bro honestly I was
doing this segment I we came up with
called First and 15 where I would like
spit a freestyle and make a beat at the
same time so so it got the attention of
my boy 200 the former senior vice
president of Def Jam yeah yeah shout out
to Mr Clark yeah tour that's my dudes my
boy he's living on AZ now yeah doing his
thing man he's he on his r b [__] right
now but uh the interns yeah the intern
shout out co-signed too my guys but uh
yeah he he he saw me and I thought it
was spam he DM me he was like yo I want
to [__] with you and I'm like yeah all
right this [__] said he's senior vice
president he's trying to hack my page
where the [__] is this guy and he was
real you know he hit me and um we had
one conversation and from there two
weeks later he was in Houston and we was
talking about you know the business and
he locked it in is it weird like if
someone brings you in and they end up
changing positions or not being there
anymore absolutely because we always
hear that that happens to an artist
where like they'll get shelved or like
the energy will change for them in a
building because the people who brought
them in aren't there anymore right now
for sure it's definitely it's definitely
different but I would say I was blessed
and put in a position where it all
worked out in my favor and two of us was
a hard worker still is a hard working
and he you know he um he fought for me
so that's my dog for life have any of
these OG rappers tried to DM me with the
mixtape scheme
yeah so
absolutely you get like a DM and you're
like a show
like what the [__] and then it's like yo
yo I see what you're doing right for 800
I got a slot on a mixtape for you the
same you gotten those DMS absolutely
I'm not gonna say no names but I got
those DMS what city are they from they
from all over
Eight Mile all over the United States
baby a lot I mean look shout out to uh
you know a lot of guys have been doing
that right the game uh Benny The Butcher
right Jadakiss a lot of those guys Fat
Joe
no names man but you know I definitely
got and I'm like [__] I know the same
[__] y'all know what the [__] what I
what yeah I had a friend of mine from
Phoenix that genuinely thought he was
talking to the game yeah and he was like
so excited yeah and he hit me he's like
bro I know you no game bro like just
co-sign me and he sent me the screenshot
and I was like
I got a feeling damn that that's not him
dming you you have the voicemail box of
ah just the hunch right just the
hunchman automated messaging man yeah so
uh what was uh the tour like man
obviously joiner's a crazy Lyricist
Simba's a crazy Lyricist shout out to
those guys dope artists yeah what was uh
that because that was that your first
like kind of big tour no no what what
tour were we on before that Lupe put me
on I was on the stepping lasers tour uh
spy dates and I did the whole generation
lasers too well [__] hey at 11 years
old I think at 11. yeah I was on two at
11. that was like my first major tour
we're gonna talk about that in a second
let's do it but
you know what [__] the Joyner Lucas and
somebody no no no I don't it was a great
tour I'm sure you had a great [__]
time absolutely I went there I saw it
whatever it was dope you were 11 on tour
with Lupe absolutely how does that
happen man my DJ was his DJ
Simon Says DJ Simon Says man and Luke
you know he's he's like a big brother he
was like a you know a real a real Mentor
so he was like I'm gonna bring a little
[__] on the road I feel like Lupe had
he like cared about rap more I mean he
cares about rap but I feel like if he
would have just played the game a little
like I think Lupe could have been the
greatest of all time I think the
Kendrick before Kendrick I think
lyrically
he he's like if we're talking about
lyrics he's probably top 10 ever I agree
like murals absolutely murals pen and
the needles like Lupe Fiasco is a
[__] alien yeah for sure and I think
we forget that because like I feel like
he kind of I think the industry kind of
did him wrong you know what I'm saying I
feel like he kind of like scorned him a
bit and I'm like did you say that you
can say that because lasers came out
I mean he had hits on lasers but what
but it wasn't the cool you know what I'm
saying
I feel like he I feel like he's like you
said you know it's it's kind of like if
you know you know you know what I'm
saying if you know you know but he's one
of the greatest of all time 100 one of
the dopest so you were getting mentored
by him at 11. for sure what was that
like I mean because he's a very
particular guy at that I mean he's also
like a [__] Samurai yeah no he was
like a [__] dad like he was like he
would be in his [__] dressing room
drinking ginger tea and doing yoga and
[__] [__] was yoked up cut up also kind
of like a low-key Fashion Icon but the
Japanese denim Japanese yeah yeah you
know your [__] bro for sure because my
DJ used to get me packs of clothes from
from Japan and he was like this is Louis
people so I used to rock all that [__]
on tour yeah he kind of put all that
[__] on it absolutely lose the dude so
that was laser so that was yeah that was
because I was living in Vegas when
lasers came out so were you around like
Pooh Bear and all those guys that's my
dude I got two records with Pooh Bear
man yeah for sure when you were 11 or
like I was like 13 14. did you go to
Molly Mall's house no okay no just gotta
make sure man nah nah about that Molly
Mall window for Pooh bear no no you
never went over there once no here thank
you it's because you got good parents
yeah for sure shout out moms did you did
you hear about Molly Malone's house as a
child no okay Lupe was over there a lot
yeah I don't want to hear about it now
does it sound like some [__] I don't
want to hear about it's a place in Las
Vegas okay okay a lot of people would
record there though to be fair like The
Motto by Drake was recorded there dope
they Franny and Molly Mo at the crib oh
okay shut up okay okay for sure now I
recorded a lot of that [__] at um 1500
another Studio okay yeah Ranch and Brody
those my guys fluff and all those guys
were you around nip at all yeah they
were over there a lot yeah for sure I
mean so you're like a [__] a young
old head young old [__] I didn't say
that yeah no that's what I call myself
well yeah I can't say that I mean you
know listen do you want to win some
money gotta stop the interview but
listen there's so many opportunities to
gamble to bet on your favorite sports to
make Sports more interesting NFL season
is over but it's all good because the
opportunities to wind are just getting
started yeah look there's so many things
you can do we're talking about NCAA NBA
NHL UFC boxing there's Blackjack
tournaments so much money to get in on
and check this out y'all if you sign up
right now using the promo code bootleg
do it right now you can get a welcome
bonus up to a thousand dollars plus
you're gonna get a free 150
000 March Madness bracket contest entry
that's
mybookie.ag use the promo code bootleg
right now get a bonus up to a thousand
dollars you're gonna put in 200 bucks
they could give you 200 you put in a
thousand they'll give you another
thousand right look right now go to
mybookie.ag sign up use that promo code
March Madness is upon us so much great
Sports just NBA season playoffs are on
the way man you could like literally put
together some crazy props like uh I
don't know over under on a player that
you like scoring you could do a future
on the MVP you think Yoki which is going
to win it you think Joel embiid is going
to win it Whatever It Is get in on the
action right now mybookie.ag with that
promo code bootleg when you sign up get
that free deposit bonus all right bet
anything anytime anywhere with my bookie
also shout out to our family at hardean
hardean Las Vegas Yes you see him
I was just there in Vegas yesterday this
is the best place I've ever been to in
terms of dispensaries I've been to
probably hundreds of these things and
the experience at hardean is like
nowhere else
the customer service the selection of
Premium cannabis the experience as a
customer that you get when you walk into
the building in Las Vegas is a bar none
the best it's just the best man they are
the best we got so much going on this
weekend they're sponsoring the Rolling
Stone party on Friday Super Bowl weekend
fabulous Thursday offset Friday Meek
Saturday it's a lot going on with hard
Dean you got to follow him at Harding
underscore Las Vegas right now shoot
them a follow on Instagram while you're
at it go to their website
hardinglasvegas.com so much fly gear so
much fly weed what are we talking about
baby shout out to hardine man that's the
family man go if you're in Vegas pull up
on them man Jardine Las Vegas I mean
yeah I mean you've been doing this [__]
for like more than most people who've
been doing it so does it feel good to
kind of like know that like you were
right the whole time because I mean
listen I'm sure you've been doing music
for 12 years or however long
you know there's probably Peaks and
valleys in in every artist's journey in
fact you know what I mean like did you
ever like
I guess feel like man maybe I shouldn't
be doing this [__] maybe I should try to
do something else
yeah and no at the same time because it
was like I felt like I kind of got a
head start because I started so young
but you know growing up coming up you
know I was still in regular school doing
a lot of that [__] I was in public
school on 106 and Park crazy so it was
like damn you know
I was in the middle but I always knew
like this it has to pay off because I'm
putting in numerous amounts of effort
you know
thousand hours and just staying focused
on my craft so I knew at the end of the
day it was going to pay off and you know
we we at the beginning of the it's also
tough I'm sure to be like a kid who's
like super lyric because like I think we
all look at kid rappers like a certain
way especially back then there was like
a certain uh stigma to them right you
know what I mean like I would never like
listen to Little Romeo as a grown-up you
know what I mean damn even if like
Lupe if Lupe Fiasco had walked you to my
radio show when you were 11 or 12 years
old and been like this kid is fire I'd
be like yeah I'm sure he is I'm not
gonna listen to him because he's a
little kid right I can't relate to this
kid okay you know what I'm saying so I
think it's dope that you got to kind of
like experience
a lot of ins and outs of this [__] so
now that you're 23 and you got a deal
with Def Jam and you're you know I feel
like you know you're like again you're
like a new artist but you have so much
experience experience already that you
can apply to this [__] because a lot of
people get they get wrapped up in this
[__] and they they spend money on the
wrong [__] or they focus on the wrong
[__] or they get lost in this [__] in
fact you got your mom here your sisters
are here you know what I mean so how
important is it to keep your family
around very very I feel like to have a
solid foundation is the key to being you
know secure whatever you know when
whatever you're doing with whatever
you're doing and I came out super super
lyrical 10 11 years old so it wasn't
believable so we had to switch to the
kid market and that's how I got the
record with my boy shout out Jacob
Latimore I went on tour Mindless
Behavior at 12 and 13. yeah so it was
like a bunch of [__] tours oh yeah
for sure for sure so I feel like
everything happens for a reason and it's
just a part of my story you know what
I'm saying Mindless Behavior yeah those
are my dogs girls are loving that man oh
yeah of a show yeah I was telling people
in school I'm feeling going two of my
behavior like yeah right right yeah
right when I came to the [__] NRG
arena in Houston and then they saw you
okay this [__] ain't lying how was it
when you went back to school the next
day oh my God was the [__] man you
were the man what because you were in
public school the whole time I was in
public school like oh you're lit in
school what the the principal everybody
was like he's causing a distraction to
the children they I had to get out of
school I had to do homeschool for a year
did the uh was it was it like ever at
issue juggling girlfriends in school no
no no I was I was I was always player
player yeah I played my cards right yeah
so
a senior a junior got a sophomore you
know what I mean they don't got the same
classes they don't know each other
that's when the older chicks start
flying in for sure huh you had older
chicks flying in before you were 18. for
sure I'm not like flying in but like
coming in flagging in you know okay okay
I don't know about this like Mom I gotta
go somewhere this 29 year old lady is
picking me up I met her on the Mindless
Behavior tour she wanted to file some
charges on a bunch of women really what
it was it was it was good grooming
because now it was grooming all right
now I know what I'm doing now I know
what I'm doing you know earlier wait
wait so help me understand
or you're dealing with older women as a
not 18 year old for sure and your mom
finds out for sure and she's trying to
hit him with that statutory she's trying
to hit him she's trying to hit him in
their face physically and then hit him
with the law yeah oh yeah she walked in
college dorms and and caused hell Jesus
what yes right has your mom ever [__]
up a chick on your behalf no I had to
stop her though I had to stop her for
sure yeah she talked some [__] big [__]
to him so they definitely felt her right
isn't it crazy that like
never mind I won't even go I was gonna
say it's like so wild the dub like the
double standard like the fact that we're
like giving you props because you were
banging like chicks over 18 but if you
were like 16 sleeping with like a 25
year old dude and you're a girl it'd be
[__] wild nice jail time it's prison
time it's over it's over lock them up
lock him up man [__] right uh who do
you put on your H-Town Mount Rushmore
let's just say Texas
because you know Port Arthur is not
necessarily Houston and everyone know
his [__] Pimp C
Scarface
zero this is four right
Pimp C phase zero
PMC phase zero fat Pat slash can I do
slash sure Fat Pat slash Devin the Dude
Devin the Dude is that guy for sure
definitely the dude is that guy yeah
sure I love Devin the Dude have you
heard of this guy from Dallas named big
X the plug he dope he's [__] hard as
hell for Joe I [__] I just I threw on
like some playlist that he has like some
song called Texas that [__] is crazy I
was like who the [__] is this
I like dived into his [__] and I'm like
and he's from doubt like Dallas I mean
you know Dallas a rest in peace to mo3
right there's some some you know Texas
is bubbling man hey we gotta stop the
interview to tell you about our good
folks that blue chew baby that's right A
lot of people keep asking me does
Bluetooth work [__] yeah it does and if
you don't believe me they'll give you a
whole month for free right now if you go
to bluetooth.com and use that promo code
bootleg that's bootry.com promo code
bootleg you get a month of blue chew for
free delivered to your [__] house all
you do is pay five dollars in shipping
what is blue tree you ask well let me
tell you it has the same active
ingredient as Viagra and Cialis in a
chewable tablet but it is discreetly
delivered right to your doorstep no
awkward doctor's visits imagine going
and telling uh an old guy about your
dick
you would prefer not to do that I know
I'd prefer not to do that you know but
you can do it all online bluetooth.com
you don't have to go to the doctor's
appointment in person no more no they're
going to send it straight to your door
all right your wife won't even know it
came your wife won't know
that you came and it came all right so
what you do is
you uh you go to bluetooth.com use the
promo code bootleg and you get a month
of uh the whole thing for free that's
right a month supply of Bluetooth for
free straight to your door they also
just drop their new mint chewable which
is the same exact active ingredient as
Levitra so many options for you at
Bluetooth to make sure your dick is
right going into the springtime baby
look spring break's coming uh are you
gonna be coming
the real question is
is your partner gonna be coming
not with the noodle dick
let's be honest make sure that shit's
hard as [__]
go to bluetooth.com use the promo code
bootleg and get a month supply for free
and if you're dealing with erectile
dysfunction it's okay man
it happens to the best of us go to
Bluetooth and put a Band-Aid on that
thing bluetooth.com promo code bootleg
also
while we're talking about our partners
shout out to our family at Odd Socks oh
look at these Odd Socks underwear man
they're they're Half Baked
so much going on at Odd Socks uh so many
dope licenses man shout out to uh they
got Cheetos they got Jaws [__] Oreos
Cheech and Chong Naruto WWE by the way
WrestleMania is coming I can't wait to
see what dope WrestleMania socks they do
this year because last year they knocked
it out the park at Odd Socks look the
most comfortable socks in the world they
got The Odd Socks Basics that you need
on your feet uh all you gotta do is go
to oddsoxofficial.com right now use the
promo code bootleg at checkout you'll
save 20 off your total order underwear
socks
[__] hats whatever you need they got it
at Odd Socks uh they just got the
Coca-Cola deal so you go get some
Coca-Cola draws Coca-Cola socks so much
always going on in Odd Socks I'm gonna
always say my favorites are the WWE in
the Breaking Bad Ones
um so go to oddsoxofficial.com right now
use that promo code bootleg and you will
save 20 off at checkout shout out to
them most comfortable socks in the world
crazy comfortable underwear my goodness
if you ain't got Odd Socks on your feet
and ass what are you doing out in these
streets all right go to
hotsoxofficial.com promo code bootleg
save 20 off let's get back to the
interview for you did you find it kind
of like it being a challenge making the
kind of music and rapping the way you
rap
trying to make it out of your city
a little bit you know because coming
from the south it's so much it is so
many shoes to feel just with the culture
you know what I'm saying and
but I feel like I feel like I made that
way to let people know that you know we
got something to say backing what Andre
said you know what face did because you
know those guys were like the first
Goodie Mob too hey Chamillionaire could
rap too I mean I can wrap his ass off
for sure absolutely I mean all these
guys can rap I mean I'm a huge fan of
Houston Hip-Hops absolutely I just think
it's like a specific style that people
look for when they think of Houston
right I mean absolutely do you have a
grill just off GP because you're from
H-Town no but I want one damn I've had
two grills for sure I lived in Florida
and they just made them for me okay okay
you had the golden yeah okay
and then I was at the strip club once
and I got made fun of by a girl that I
liked and I was like never wearing these
yeah okay maybe this is not for me right
also if you wear a grill you have to
clean the grill absolutely no that [__]
most [__] who wear grills have
god-awful breath it's a terrible thing
because they don't you have to clean the
grill every time you wear it otherwise
your mouth smells like [__] metal
gingivitis oh my God it's a bad look man
um what's what's going on with you
musically right now album coming what's
out like what's going on I'm definitely
coming I got my latest album the mecca
that dropped uh we're working on Singles
and just putting content up but
definitely more music coming definitely
more music do you feel like uh because
you know right now in hip-hop there is I
feel like
you know I feel like there's a void for
what you are doing and what a guy like
Simba is doing and a guy like Russell
and you know I do feel like like we kind
of need a breath of fresh air in hip-hop
do you feel similar for sure yeah
because I do feel like you know
we're kind of like out of the SoundCloud
area thank God you know what I mean but
there's definitely I feel like uh the
lyricism is you know it's needed right
now and I feel like it's being more
appreciated now because I feel like we
we got through like a [__] weird era
of rap where it was it was like all time
low and I feel like we're kind of on the
other side of it so
for sure I agree I feel the same way
it's like good who's somebody right now
that you're you're liking in terms of
like maybe a peer or just someone who
you're a fan of that maybe you
necessarily don't have a relationship
with already [__] with baby king
uh love baby cam yeah baby keems dope
man
[__] with baby drill uh
symbol of course dope
um
it's a lot of new guys man I can't
really think of I listen to all type of
music you know what I'm saying but those
are the ones I could think of off the
bat anybody on the new album that you're
working on
no no features as of now as of right now
as of now
you go to the streamville Fest you meet
J Cole what are you telling J Cole man
you you are one of my biggest
Inspirations [__] you're the [__]
truth [__] [__] with you
for sure yeah that's a good thing to
tell them absolutely for sure because
him and Kendrick is like him Kendrick
and Drake
I feel like there will be no me without
those guys you know what I'm saying
would you say that like uh because
they're kind of like
the three heads on the Mount Rushmore of
the last like 10 years for sure the
fourth spot is debatable
yeah you can say that you can say that I
think it's Kanye because I think Kanye
could put on the Mountain Rush more in
the last like 20 years for two eras I
think but
I think you could put like
it's really those three and then the
fourth spot you know you can make
different cases for futures or you know
it's a bunch of guys but I feel like I'm
stepping into the next decade you know
I'm saying I'm one of those guys that
could be the front runner of the next
the next 10 years right and do what they
did you still keep in touch with Lupe I
haven't talked to Lou in a minute but
that's still my dog I talked to Aunt and
Bishop all the time so yo you should get
man because the the last Lupe album was
actually pretty fire yeah for sure
absolutely yeah it was yeah Lupe's on
man
to learn that about you man because I
think a lot of times like
you know when we think of like these new
artists man
I feel like
they make so many mistakes like I was
saying so it's good to know that you got
you know a good team behind you bro
absolutely so uh the Mecca's out right
now yes sir new project coming soon yes
sir do we know the name of the new
project
it's in the air right now but I'm I'm
strongly leaning on dear me love me okay
dear me love me
sure Mom ever help you write the wraps
no no no she gave me inspiration but no
she never give you like a bar or nothing
no she gave me like topics and
challenges like use these words in a rap
like she was like a [__] rap major
pain because she oh [__] so she'd be
like for sure I need you to write a
[__] rap about for sure take 10 words
out of the dictionary use them in a
sentence use them in a paragraph wow and
write a rap with them look at you you
just had it lit as a kid for sure man it
was it was a hard work but it paid off
you know and I'm still developing my
craft yeah I still have every day to get
better with you keep doing your thing
Marcus clay we about to have him do a
freestyle I'm gonna be a separate
YouTube video go check out the mecca out
now baby new music soon running loud
this weekend
dreamville Fest April boom